So we kind of postponed that surgery.
My broken pelvis and I were now facing six weeks on the couch,
and I would have gone absolutely insane if it hadn't been for my friends.
Spontaneous parties broke out at my house every night for weeks.
I was fed. I was entertained.
It was great.
But that kind of enthusiasm is sort of hard to sustain over the long term,
and eventually it petered down to just one friend,
who would send me jokes during the day
and come and keep me company in the evenings --
someone I got to know a whole lot better during this period of convalescence.
And when I was finally pronounced well enough
to do weight-bearing activities,
we loaded a telescope in the car and drove up into the mountains
to look at the Hale–Bopp comet.
Yes, we are geeks.
And got caught in a landslide.
(Laughter)
I know -- like, really?
No. Just kidding.
(Laughter)
No more disasters. No. Just the opposite, in fact.
That was 21 years ago,
and for 19 of those years,
I have been married to that marvelous introvert
who never in a million years would have approached me
under other circumstances.
We have a wonderful 14-year-old daughter,
who did all my illustrations.
(Cheers and applause)
Yeah.
So, pro tip:
apparently, nothing makes you sexier than needing a walker
on your first date.
So this isn't a story about piercings
or sharks or boilings or breakings.
It's a love story.
It's a love story with a funny little epilogue.
Now I was weight-bearing again, I could reschedule that surgery,
get the spine out.
But I didn't need it anymore.
Turns out, when you break a bone,
your body scavenges calcium from all the bones in your body --
and from the little sea urchin spine that you happen to have lodged
in the joint of your finger.
So yes,
my pelvis is now part sea urchin.
(Laughter)
So to biology brain, physicist brain,
adrenaline brain, warm-blooded-mammal brain,
I get to add "urchin brain,"
with all of the superpowers that that confers.
You don't need to worry, though:
that I am not fully human is one of the things
that my family loves the most about me.
(Laughter)
Thank you very much.
(Applause)